good morning Hank it's Wednesday puffs
levels are high thang as you can tell
from the tiffy odometer I've made quite
a bit of progress I am now over 80
thousand copies which would be great
except I got a call a couple days ago
from my publisher saying that I had to
get up here 250,000 copies by November
3rd so basically I have to sign between
three and four thousand copies a day
which takes between nine and twelve now
it's just pretty time-consuming so I
apologize but my videos are gonna suck
for the next month and jump cut by the
way before I descend deeper into signing
madness let me tell you a cute story so
the other day I went out into the
backyard with Henry and I was showing
him like flowers and our tomatoes and I
was explained to him about like sunlight
and pollen and bees and the magic of it
all and then he looked at me and he said
TV on I don't watch a lot of TV with
Henry although lately because of the
signing I've had to watch some but the
best part about when he watches TV is
that he always walks up to the TV and he
pokes it because he thinks it's an iPad
right but about signing walk with me so
let me give you a quick tour the
situation out right so this is the
approximate number of boxes I have to
sign and these are empty boxes you'll
see their contents in a moment and this
is the current sad pile of blue guys
and/or cinema jigs I will put you guys
back in the background when I'm finished
and then I actually sign the books up
here using a Sharpie with this thing
that my occupational therapist Allen
gave me by the way shout out to my
occupational therapist I think I have
the weirdest occupation he's ever theft
but he's been very nice about it and yes
Hank I know the Lighting's bad I told
you my videos are gonna be bad until
this is over over here we have large
stacks of signed sheets and then here
are tens of thousands of more signed
sheets waiting to be boxed including one
that's yet Ede so Hank the yetis kind
enough to sit with me and watch TV at
night while I sign but she gets bored so
sometimes she yetis them there's jumping
Yeti
there's Yeti standing atop Mount J a
Yeti clinging to the scribble and then
sometimes there's just the Yeti hanging
out at the bottom and here's my bag full
of used sharpies I've got about 300
years sharpies Hank and I'm only just
more than halfway done a guy could freak
out about it you know but I try not to
freak out I just try to like you know
keep calm and dftba is there's chilly
stain there sorry about that I've been
wearing this shirt for a few days I'm
not gonna lie to you Hank I'm not taking
a lot of showers right now I changed
because I realized that we had chilly
over the weekend so hey long story short
for the next month or so puffed levels
may be high I may seem or even
he crazy my videos might suck but I am
going to sign every copy of The Fault in
Our Stars nerdfighters thank you for
giving me such a wonderful problem by
the way if you're wondering what my
hands are doing what I'm always signing
those aren't even bad I should sign
without looking more often Hank by the
way great joke to the CERN physicist
when he was like what's keeping you from
falling to the center of the earth and
you were like my chair I'll see you on
Friday
wait one more thing the iPhone 4s is
just like the iPhone 4 no we have a
chance to be part of a feature film
being made by my friend Amy cross
Rosenthal my longtime collaborator who's
doing the beckoning of lovely if you
don't know what that is it's a thing
where a me and other people beckon
lovely into the world Amy wants people
from all over the world to design their
own greetings based on the beckoning of
lovely anagram evoking bent eco folly so
for example here's one that Amy made and
here's one that my friend Stan and I
made okay there you can click on my face
and/or puff to go to a video that shows
you how to participate and you can learn
more about the beckoning of lovely which
is an amazing beautiful wonderful
project that's been going on for three
years now okay I really got to go sign
now